America's money supply is shrinking
right now Signature Bank marks the third
largest bank failure in U.S history is
the United States bracing itself for a
domino effect of bank failures this is a
massive economic warning and it's
something that hasn't happened in more
than 90 years and guess what happened
during the other times when our money
supply contracted we had the banking
crisis of the 1870s the Panic of 1893
the depression of 1921 and the Great
Depression of 1929. during each of these
previous crashes America faced the
horrors on more than 10 unemployment and
massive bank failures which is what
could be waiting for us in the very near
future and this is sending Banks into
panic mode yo in many respects what
we're living through today is a very
Traditional Bank run but the shrieking
money supply is not the only sign that
things are about to go from bad to worse
years later people are going to look
back at this period and say man all the
warning signs were there had we not see
it coming but you won't be one of those
people because we're gonna go over all
the dire warning signs that are
happening right now in this video so
stay dangerous and let's get into it
foreign
[Music]
to continue making more money and
leveling up I have to be constantly
reading books but the problem is not all
books are created equal some books are
way more important than others for you
and the way I think about it is that 20
of the books out there will give you 80
of the results you're looking for so
your job is to shift through as many
books as possible to get to that 20 take
this book for example the psychology of
money I love reading money books but a
lot of them are repetitive I don't want
to invest time into reading this if it's
not going to help me so what I did
instead is I first went through a
summary of the book on an app called
short form and because of the summary I
found out that this book actually had a
lot of stuff I had not learned yet so
then I bought the full book in Reddit
and one of the most important points I
got from it is about how getting wealthy
requires risk however once you have
wealth staying wealthy requires the
exact opposite paranoia which no one
ever talks about and it was all thanks
to short form short form offers the best
book summaries out there on over a
thousand non-fiction books and what's
great is that their summaries aren't
superficial they're actually super
in-depth it's more of a book guide
versus a book summary and you'll find
that the key insights you get from
reading the actual Book You'll most
likely find it in short form and they
even include cool side notes linking to
other books that provide counter
arguments like this note that references
another book called anti-fragile by one
of my favorite authors to love so I
highly recommend giving short form a try
and if you use my link below right now
shortfrom.com Jake Tran you'll get a
free trial and 50 off the annual
subscription which is over three months
free that means for the price of one
book a month you'll get access to
thousands of short form book guides
pause the video and go to shortfrom.com
with the link below now thanks to short
film for sponsoring this video
[Music]
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
banks have stopped lending they stop
giving out so many loans which is really
really really bad because the American
economy is completely reliant on debt to
keep growing just take a look at this
graph whenever you see corporate debt go
down just by a tiny bit just a tiny bit
that's when the economy crashes and goes
into a recession as indicated by the
gray areas and it looks like this is
what's happening right now as we speak
if you look at how the graph is starting
to Flatline right now this is because
Banks aren't lending as much anymore
quote Commercial Bank lending dropped
nearly 105 billion dollars in the two
weeks ended March 29th the most in
Federal Reserve data back to 1973 End
quotes
and the lows I've seen the biggest drops
are real estate loans commercial loans
and Industrial loans this is because of
two things one interest rates are almost
as high as they were in 2008 so lows
aren't as affordable anymore so people
are taking out less loans but it's also
because Banks don't have that much money
to lend out just take first for a public
bank for example right before they
crashed their deposits were done 36
percent compared to the year before but
their loans were still up by 23 which
meant that they were loaning out more
money than people were depositing so to
save itself from collapsing like Silicon
Valley Bank First Republic Bank has the
cutback on its loans to account for
those fewer deposits and First Republic
Bank is not the only bank that is doing
this people all over America are moving
their money into the big five banks like
Chase because they're afraid of more
Bank runs which is ironically making the
smaller Banks more vulnerable to bank
runs so these banks are cutting back on
how many loans they give out which means
there are going to be fewer mortgages
business loans credit and less overall
money available in the economy the
Silicon Valley Bank crisis which saw
second biggest bank failure in U.S
history now the US government kind of
stepped in to save the day and rescue
the depositors there so we didn't have
you know crazy depression or panic but
the problem is that that banking run and
banking crisis for Silicon Valley bank
now scared all the other banks in the
financial system none of the other Banks
want to be the next bank that has a bank
run so that's causing the banks to get
cautious and to cut back the lending
that they're doing into the U.S economy
so my name is Nick I run a YouTube
channel called re-venture Consulting
where I cover all of these macro
economic topics I also have a focus on
real estate additionally I launched a
website called reventure app
www.reventure.app which allows people
who are interested in buying a house to
look at the housing market data in their
area and to figure out whether home
prices are going to go up or down into
the future
you can see periods where the bank
credit growth heavily decelerates like
it is now or turns negative are
associated with recessions which are
these gray bars so when you see the gray
bar notice how wow Bank credit growth
goes down uh that happened in the uh mid
to late 2000s before the great financial
crisis that happened in 2000 before
the.com bust that happened in the early
90s before the Gulf War recession that
happened in the late 70s and early 80s
in the inflation recessions back then so
declining Bank credit what's going on
right now we're only at 2.7 percent
growth year over year that's one of the
lowest levels we've seen in credit
expansion since the data series started
50 60 years ago which basically means
we're in a credit crunch banks are
choking off liquidity from the economy
because they don't want to be the next
Silicon Valley Bank instead of making
the loan they're keeping the money in
cash on their balance sheet cracks are
starting to form in the Empire and one
of the first potential consequences of
this are going to be the average middle
class workers
this graph tracks total business and
corporate debt in America over the last
70 years what do you see I mean it's
gone up a lot we have basically 20
trillion dollars in business and
corporate debt which is fueling our
economy is fueling the employment where
do people get them where do the
companies get the money to employ the
people from here from this corporate
debt and so when uh Banks cut back
lending this corporate debt is
invariably going to start to go down and
what's scary is that it doesn't need to
even go down by a lot to have big
problems I mean take a look back at the
great financial crash 0809 right worst
recession since the Great Depression
corporate debt peaked in 2008 at like 10
trillion and then all it did was go go
from like 10.7 trillion down to 10
trillion
and that basically facilitated the worst
recession and downturn we've seen in
America in like 90 years and so we're
basically addicted to debt as a country
to fuel our economy particularly in the
corporate sector and if banks cut back
lending more we're going to see this
corporate debt go down which is going to
mean businesses have to lay off workers
and a lot of them are gonna have to shut
down
foreign
crunch affects is employment if most of
America's businesses run on debts on
taking out loans to buy inventory and
pay employees the minute these
businesses can't get more loans to stay
afloats they're gonna have to make some
tough choices one they're gonna have to
lay off their least essential employees
or two they can keep drawing on their
deposits and their bank accounts which
is going to mean banks are going to have
even less money to lend out which is
going to make the economy go down even
more or three they're gonna have to take
out risky loans at really really high
interest rates but whatever the right
they choose the middle class will
continue to be squeezed as they always
have and this isn't some way off
dystopian future it's already happening
quote U.S Factory activity contracted in
March to its lowest level since May 2020
as measures of new orders and employment
retreated End quotes you know if you
look at the headline unemployment rate
it's three and a half percent which
suggests a strong job market so some
people are kind of being maybe tricked
into thinking the economy is healthy
right now but when you look at the
leading indicators for the economy like
retail and consumer spending that just
dropped off huge in March when you look
at bank lending banks are cutting back
lending at the fastest rate in 15 to 20
years right now that's going to be bad
for the economy in the future but it's
going to be businesses can't get loans
and are going to have to lay off workers
when you look at Wall Street earnings
reports earnings and profits for Wall
Street companies every single month now
are going down and we're going to have
the biggest decline in Wall Street
profits and earnings that we've had
since the pandemic in the first quarter
of 2023 which is going to mean you know
Wall Street companies lose money or less
profit they're gonna have to lay off
workers and so you know the leading
indicators of the economy are suggesting
problems in the economy ahead and that
that 3.5 unemployment rate is not going
to last for very long and as more and
more people get laid off it will cost a
bloodbath in the real estate markets
foreign
if you want to understand the real
estate market you have to understand
that 58 of Americans already live
paycheck to paycheck while almost half
of Americans have less than a thousand
dollars saved they are already teetering
on the edge so if and when they get laid
off they are gonna be squeezed the ones
that own homes won't be able to pay
their mortgage and the ones that rent
won't be able to afford their current
rents and well you can imagine the rest
so debt to income ratio basically tells
you how stressed the homeowner is in
being able to afford their payments and
let's just do an example an affordable
debt to income ratio would be 20 or 25
percent meaning that the homeowner is
only paying 20 to 25 percent of their
income towards their debt payments each
month and you know the general rule of
thumb is like if you're below 30 you
know you're good however the problem is
right now the FHA debt to income ratio
in mid 2022 is 45 for home buyers and so
they're on average paying 45 of their
income on their debt costs and that
leaves very little wiggle room for
things to go wrong right like say
they're out get cut or say they get laid
off or say they don't get the raise they
thought they were going to get or say
maybe their car breaks down and they
need to fix their car buy a new car
there isn't the room there uh for those
extra expenses and that increases the
likelihood and odds that they end up
defaulting on their mortgage and then
eventually would be foreclosed on so
right now uh the U.S government gives
first-time home buyers these very risky
loans to buy a house they typically only
need to put three to five percent down
and they can borrow so much that they'd
be paying over 50 percent of their
income and mortgage interest in debt in
a year and basically these loans now for
FHA borrowers are riskier today than
they were at the peak of the previous
bubble in 2008 so contrary to the
conventional wisdom that all the loans
in the housing market are good loans
this time around that's not true there's
a lot of risky loans particularly in
this FHA segment where lots of borrowers
actually already defaulting you know
scary statistic right now is that the
FHA mortgage default rate is 12 right
now over one out of every 10 FHA
mortgages in America is already in
default
and that's with an unemployment rate
that's only 3.5 percent so we're still
at the lowest unemployment rate ever in
U.S history right now and yet we still
have lots lots of defaults already going
on so what happens if the unemployment
rate doubles in this recession the FHA
mortgage default rate with all these
people with three percent down payments
and paying 50 of their income to their
mortgage that they're going to go go
more into default and so that's the
unfortunate situation that uh the US
government has set up for us here and
it's not just these first-time home
buyer mortgages that are at risk the
debt to income ratio on normal mortgages
are also probably equally as high this
would be the debt to income situation
for all home purchase mortgages uh
including FHA including Fannie Mae
including um you know non-government
backed and you can see in the middle of
2022 we were at 38 now in the last
couple quarters it's going to be even
higher because mortgage rates came up
but Fannie Mae doesn't have that data
yet but we could see 38 percent
that's roughly equivalent to what it was
in 0.706 a little bit less maybe it was
a little bit less in 2020 when rates
were lower but you could see we're in
the same ballpark basically in terms of
home buyers across the entire mortgage
Market being stressed on their ability
uh to make their interest payments
America has kicked the can down a road
for far too long from the zero interest
rates after 2008 to the insane money
printing of coven every time we've
postponed the pain the bubble has just
gotten bigger and bigger so one of two
things can happen either the government
and the FED find yet another way to Kick
the Can down the road again or the
economy is in for a bloodbath a
bloodbath that those who are prepared
will be able to profit from all we can
see is if you're not stacking cash right
now what on Earth are you doing and if
you want to learn the most practical way
to start stacking cash the route that I
recommend is getting a war from home job
because think about it as companies lay
off people in droves to save money
they're still gonna need someone to get
the job done so who are they going to
turn to they're gonna turn to remote
workers that don't need expensive office
space that don't require a bunch of
overhead and by hiring more work from
home positions not only does the company
save money but you still make really
good money working wherever you want
whenever you want and before YouTube
This is actually the route I took I I
lended a 40 per hour work from home job
at only 19 years old without a degree in
hardly any experience and this work from
home job changed everything for me and I
was able to land this work from home job
without a degree in experience because
of very specific strategies that I came
up with to increase my odds of getting
hired even though there were definitely
other candidates out there that were way
more qualified than me and I put all my
findings and all my strategies into our
new masterclass called exploit the
system exploit the system is the best
masterclass out there on how to land a
work from home job as fast as possible
even if you don't have a degree or
experience where I walk you through step
by step on exactly what to do over the
course of 90 Plus premium video lessons
this course is a perfect fit for you if
you want to make money online but you
also don't want to slave away 12 hours a
day trying to build a business from
scratch or this course is also for you
if you want to start a business but you
still want a flexible way to make money
while you build your business on the
side which is what I did and how do I
know this course actually works because
it's worth for our students and if you
want to learn more and hear what they
have to say click the score on the
screen to watch our free video on this
masterclass right now click the square
on the screen to watch now
[Music]